[Música]
y con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar del mundial de Qatar que
comienza este domingo 20 de noviembre
ese mundial envuelto en muchísimas
apolémicas polémicas en torno a los
Derechos Humanos también en polémicas en
todo esta milla extra digamos o como se
dice de los jugadores que se han
lesionado y figuras importantísimas de
varias selecciones del mundo que no van
a estar presentes en este mundial de
Qatar mundial de Qatar también que va en
contra de muchísimas políticas del
cambio climático Mejor dicho hay muchas
preguntas y muchos temas sobre la mesa
que vamos a tratar con el mar está por
supuesto nuestra cronista de deportes
que nos va a acompañar en este segmento
de hoy del invitado del día y también
Guillermo noll él es analista deportivo
profesor y periodista autor entre otros
de manual de curiosidades mundiales y la
música y el fútbol Guillermo Gracias por
estar con nosotros mañana de viernes en
directo América de Francia 24 Omar te
doy la palabra para que comiences un
placer Guillermo Saludos y comenzamos
preguntándole es un mundial que va
contracorriente de lo que suelen ser los
mundiales de fútbol normalmente las
ligas finales de abril principios de
mayo están parando para que los equipos
tengan por lo menos unos 40 días de
preparación antes de que se inicie el
mundial y aquí estamos en una situación
en la que hasta el domingo había hombres
jugando en sus respectivas ligas que se
puede esperar en lo deportivo de un
mundial digamos con con esta
circunstancia en lo que tiene que ver
con calendarios
Sí qué tal Buenos días para todos es una
fecha muy extraña no pensando que el
primer mundial fue el que se realizó más
tarde empezó el 13 de julio y terminó el
30 del mismo mes estamos hablando de
1930 y este mundial de alguna manera no
lleva a un momento
distinto en el tiempo para disputar un
mundial con una falencia que no se ha
pensado para mí entender que los
jugadores que juegan en ligas
sudamericanas Llevan como carga una
temporada entera no tanto los europeos
lo que juegan en el fútbol europeo y en
otras ligas que comenzaron su temporada
activa en agosto no así que Esto hace
que de alguna manera las lesiones y el
poco tiempo de preparación de hecho una
sola semana que los seleccionados tienen
a sus jugadores es algo incomprensible
Guillermo un mundial También envuelto en
muchísima polémica no que estamos viendo
sobre todo ahorita en estos últimos días
en estas últimas horas previo al pitazo
inicial de este mundial de Qatar Pero
cómo se llegó hasta ahí por qué la FIFA
digamos decidió poner acatar como sede
de este mundial entendiendo todas las
dificultades y todo lo que pues se
tendría que enfrentar para que se lleve
esta fiesta deportiva que
lamentablemente ha sido manchada sin
duda alguna por esto se pierde lo bonito
de esta emoción mundialista claro
tampoco entendimos en su momento Cómo se
designó a Rusia no O sea no fue muy
clara la designación de Rusia en este
caso la de Qatar también tiene muchas
tuvo muchas preparativos previos
preparativos entre comillas no a los
cuales se ha llegado para para jugar
este mundial si uno repasa desde un
principio se trató de que un mundial se
juegue en Europa y otro en el continente
americano claro en esas épocas en esos
tiempos otros Lares no no tenían la
infraestructura como para armar un
mundial pero con el tiempo
vivimos el mundial de coreas Japón
vivimos el mundial de Sudáfrica Y en
este caso por primera vez en un país
musulmán que me parece lógico Me parece
increíble hacerlo claro Más allá de las
costumbres y algunos temas que uno
realmente ponen dudas
quienes están llamadas a hacer las
figuras en ya pasando a lo deportivo y
tomando en cuenta que este mundial se
quedó sin muchos de los astros que se
esperaba que brillaran en esta
oportunidad Paul pog vengo locanté ahora
radio manet tampoco va a estar Ronald
Araujo estamos hablando de una cantidad
de jugadores
timo werner que que se han quedado fuera
quienes están llamados digamos a tomar
la batuta y hacer los que en lo
deportivo den brillo y den lustre este
Campeonato del mundo hay muchos
jugadores que uno siempre piensa que van
a hacer figuras Pero uno puede contar
con Cristiano Ronaldo con Messi y con
otros que han sido figuras Toni kroos o
otros jugadores que realmente tuvieron
una una destacada actuación en otros
mundiales pero siempre aparecen nuevos
jugadores figuras jóvenes con mbappé que
tuvo un gran mundial en 2018 y ahora me
viene a la mente una frase que dijo ya
fontaine el máximo goleador en la
historia mundial él auguraba Esto fue
hace unos diez años que Messi lo lo le
ganara en esa en esa anotación histórica
que tiene el de tres anotaciones el
precio de 1958 y quisiera que alguna vez
meses lo supere y llega a ser el máximo
goleador de un solo mundial cosa que por
el momento que está viviendo Lionel me
parece bastante posible lógico que hay
que cometer lo hay que hacer 13 goles o
más en un mundial Pero bueno las
perspectivas candadas para que sea un
gran mundial en donde siempre las
figuras las figuras que que han pasado
por otros torneos va a ser el quinto
mundial de Lionel Messi en este caso
igualando por ejemplo a Márquez a Rafa
Márquez o a Carvajal el Arquero mexicano
Alberto el alemán y en este caso me
parece que siempre va a haber algún
tapado siempre va a haber algún jugador
que algunos jugadores que se van a
destacar y que van a ser figuras sin
lugar a dudas Guillermo este mundial
pudiera sentar un precedente en la Fifa
en los organizadores de evento deportivo
para escoger de alguna manera unos
países con mayores libertades que no
tengas tantas trabas como lo vimos
también en las últimas horas que ya se
prohibió completamente la venta de
cerveza uno de los mayores
patrocinadores de este evento deportivo
como el xboxer
y es imposible es posible que la FIFA
tome nota de esto ya tenemos en claro
que el próximo mundial lo van a
compartir Estados Unidos México y Canadá
no se sabe a ciencia cierta del 2030
pero creo que a nivel económico es una
gran pérdida para algunas empresas
Habría que ver si la FIFA toma en cuenta
esto si toma nota de esto y Revela la
situación Más allá de los de la dudosa
designación de Qatar un país con poca
tradición futbolera ya que su liga se
inició en 1971 y no tiene una historia
futbolera y va a ser su primer mundial
no va a ser el Benjamín del mundial
hemos visto por ejemplo a la selección
de Estados Unidos
sumando los derechos los colores del
Arcoiris Para apoyar a las poblaciones
lgbti o por ejemplo hoy Países Bajos en
Inglaterra recibiendo sus sitios de
entrenamiento a migrantes trabajadores
que estuvieron en participando en la
elaboración de los mundiales hay alguna
posibilidad o o digamos Hay algún resqui
dentro del mundo del fútbol para que
sean los propios jugadores y las propios
equipos los que presionen para que ese
escenario ideal de dejar de lado hacer
es cuestionadas como Qatar pueda darse
en el futuro no creo que la FIFA de
lugar a esto en este momento De hecho
hace unos 20 años que muchos jugadores
de otra posición sexual o de otra forma
sexual han optado por por abrirse al
mundo y y saber hacer saber sus sus
deseos sexuales pero no creo que en este
momento y faltando tampoco para el
inicio del mundial sea factible eso yo
creo que lo más importante también aquí
como lo intentaba dejar ver Guillermo es
la parte económica digamos cuando
realmente Lamentablemente el dinero es
lo que mueve estos grandes eventos
deportivos cuando estas grandes marcas y
grandes partocinantes digan no voy a
caer en pérdidas porque vamos a hacer en
tal lugar y en otro hay la FIFA entonces
va a replantearselo no sé si estás de
acuerdo conmigo Mari que lo que también
pienso es hasta qué punto los jugadores
y las elecciones pueden tener voz en el
futuro no en lo inmediato para esto
bueno esa pregunta queda pues al aire
hay muchas dudas también por contestar
Omar Muchísimas gracias por acompañarme
en este espacio de invitado el día
Guillermo por supuesto Gracias a ti
también por acompañarnos esta mañana de
viernes un abrazo gracias a ustedes un
abrazo